hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures
infinity ward's most enduring mystery
throughout this wait period for Avengers
4 is what the hell was Doctor Strange
thinking like why did he surrender the
time stone to Thanos the way we gave our
for it roll-ups to those girls who'd
beat us up in grade school why didn't he
just cut off their nose his arm with
that portal you could get the gauntlet
and a bonus gift of a big severed
crippled hand with all the updates from
Captain Marvel and ant-man and the wasp
and other Avengers porn news that we've
been covering meticulously I'm going to
give my theory of what dr. Strange's
actual plan was now let's start by
reexamining Infinity Ward from dr.
Strange's perspective in the first half
of the film his primary priority is to
protect the one infinity stone in his
possession if it comes to saving you or
the kid or the time stone
I'm not hesitate to let either of you
die but after joining the guardians on
Titan Strange uses a time stone to look
at all the possible future scenarios
fourteen million six hundred and five to
be exact and he says that they only win
in one of those scenarios no we don't
see The Avengers discussing their battle
plan but it appears that strangest
strategy is to stall Thanos he stalls
him with one-on-one conversation and he
stalls them by trying to hold him down
so that they can wriggle that gauntlet
off when that fails he stalls Thanos and
a magical duel until he bargains with
Thanos by giving him the time stone in
exchange for Tony Stark's life so I
think that we can assume that everything
strange does between looking into the
future to this moment is all part of his
plan a plan that he didn't fully share
with Stark and the others a narrowly
tailored plan with specific steps and
conditions that lead to the one future
scenario of Thanos his defeat so let's
break down those conditions and I
consider there to be five big ones first
strange needed Tony Stark to be left
alive so that he can deliver the fatal
strike against Thanos I think one of the
most understated moments of the fight
against Thanos was the moment Ironman
drew blood from the mad Titan know that
for a drop of blood I think there's more
to this than we realized it's one thing
for an Asgardian demigod with a star
forged battle axe to cut Thanos his
flesh but for the human
Tony Stark to make it bleed like that
though curiously vulnerable for Thanos
and that might be because it's kind of a
callback to a moment from Iron Man 2 if
you can make God bleed
in the same way that Mickey Rourke's
seemed to miss and fail and his first
round against Stark perhaps strange
hopes Stark makes the connection that
sometimes just drawing blood is enough
to gain the confidence that you can one
day topple a giant so strange is final
duel against Thanos could have just been
more stalling to get start time to tag
in and learn this key lesson well I'm
thinking about it why go to this trouble
they were so close to removing the
gauntlet earlier you can almost see that
mrs. palm but then star-lord Peter quill
ruined it by losing his cool of her
gamora's death and punching and stano's
and his face breaking him out of his
trance so why didn't strange just remove
star-lord from the equation and open a
portal underneath him and leave him with
that hand list call obsidian on a
mountain that brings us to our second
condition I'll get to that but first
thank you door sponsor World of Tanks
blitz world of tanks blitz
it's a massive online game it's really
fun and it's free to play on iOS Android
Mac steam and Windows 10 World of Tanks
blitz features high intense battles and
tons of customization it actually just
added a new feature called the mad games
arena it's a new sandstorm battlefield
where survivors can use modded vehicles
to claim post-apocalyptic tanks there's
a scavenger and the grave digger the
scavenger actually is the most popular
vehicle in the wasteland it's super
maneuverable and good for dodging and
enemy shells meanwhile the grave digger
is awesome it's got heavy armor that's
great for ramming and a fast shooting
gun by the way these vehicles were
actually made in collaboration with
Peter pound he was a principal vehicle
designer for the movie Mad Max fury road
these things look awesome
make sure to download World of Tanks
blitz for free by clicking on the link
below or by going to spawn zorg slash
new rock stars ok back to the second
condition dr. Strange's plan strange
needed nebula to join the group in order
to use guilt to weaken Thanos another
understated game changer in Thanos is
battle was the arrival of nebula after
all it was she who confirmed that Thanos
murdered Gamora which led to quills
fateful decision and interestingly only
nebula is left alive with stark on Titan
at the end of the film also
interestingly after thanasis snapped he
has to again confront his heartbreaking
decision to sacrifice Gamora for the
soul stone
cost dude I think nebula survival is a
key condition to Thanos his eventual
defeat she knows how much it weakened
Thanos emotionally to have to kill his
favorite daughter and that guilt is
certainly something that stark can
exploit perhaps using his own guilty
memory machine barf binary augmented
retro framing and we've seen from set
photos that there is an orange briefcase
with binary Augmented retro framing
written on it it's gonna factor into the
Avengers for plot somehow I show us a
point out that in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics nebula is the one character to
steal Thanos's gauntlet and lead the way
to his defeat so I assume she must play
a role in this endgame somehow and I
think that also goes through the other
Marvel heroes who were benched for this
battle bringing us to her next condition
starting with ant-man
I think strange needed an Avenger to be
left in the quantum realm at the time of
the snap remember Doctor Strange briefly
visited the quantum realm
during this magical mystery tour through
the various realities
perhaps Strange knows that something
about the quantum realm can help them
quantum energy or someone else living in
that quantum realm city that was spotted
in the background of Ant Man in the wasp
another benched hero was Captain Marvel
I think strange needed Nick Fury to
finally summon his ace in the hole in
the final moments of Avengers infinity
war Nick Fury contacts Carol Danvers who
apparently is the most powerful Avenger
I assume that in strange his vision of
that one future scenario Captain Marvel
joins the hero lineup and the only way
to get her into the mix was to allow
Thanos to wreak such a calamitous
disaster that Nick Fury had to give her
a ring but the exact line-up of that
final assault on Thanos is probably the
most important condition Doctor Strange
needed the original Avengers to be back
on one side with the right motivation
it's pretty easy to notice that these
survivors of fantasy snap included the
original Avengers including Hawkeye who
will appear in Avengers 4 and isn't it
interesting that all these characters
witnessed a heartbreaking loss
Stark watched Peter Parker dust away in
his arms cap saw his best friend Bucky
go down Thor saw Loki and Heimdall died
earlier in the film and he could argue
that banner and Natasha are already
haunted by it all the blood on their
hands who knows who Clint could have
lost in the snap maybe it's all family
you don't get that kind of haircut on a
whim strange must know that in order for
these people to be Avengers
need something to avenge after Civil War
divided them they needed a shared sting
of defeat bring them back together and
that brings me back to the moment
strange surrenders the time stone to
Thanos why does it seem to appear from
out of nowhere hidden amongst the stars
of the background and why does it glow
as it floats over to fan OHS when as we
saw throughout the movie Infinity stones
only seem to glow
when they're being used I think the time
stone is being used in this moment by
dr. strange I think the place he was
hiding it was in the future stay with me
here it is looking more and more likely
that Avengers 4 will feature some kind
of time-travel elements or splitting
into parallel realities I've made like a
dozen videos on the subject you can
watch any of them but one possibility we
haven't really explored is this when
strange told Tony Stark we're in the
in-game now strange was clearly
referring to the game of chess the final
phase of the game in which both sides
began making key sacrifices to close in
on and checkmate the King as the
arguable smartest mind of the Marvel
Cinematic World strange is probably
playing three-dimensional chess here and
I think one of those dimensions is time
Stahl Thanos in the present on Titan
while you send the time stone itself
forward in time to the reunited Avengers
of the future who then used that time
stone to rewind the clock to keep ass
battles and fix the messes that the
Infinity stones have caused imagine an
Avengers war in which the surviving
Avengers are visited by a past
projection of dr. strange whoa I'm the
ghost of infinity war past and there was
the reason I let you lose because
nothing brings people together like
being a bunch of losers
here's the time stone I'm projecting it
from the past is it and I give it back
to me so I can trick vanos into thinking
he won once this task would be completed
strange could return back to that moment
on Titan to close the loop get Thanos to
time stone and allow the mad Titan to
set the stage the precise waste range
needs him to to have that future
conversation yes this all sounds very
complicated I know but Doctor Strange is
a very complicated man you don't look
ahead to 14 million 605 future outcomes
and not gain some crazy specific insight
into the fickle nature of cause and
effect let me know what you think what
other conditions do you think need to
have been part of dr. Strange's plan
comment down below with your thoughts
this theoretical Doctor Strange plan and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at a
boss and another reminder about war of
tanks blitz guys to support this channel
go to spawns org slash new rockstars and
there you can download and play World of
Tanks blitz for free and of course
subscribe to new rockstars to see me
pull apart of interest infinity war like
a child doing a terrifying autopsy on
his favorite toy look mommy I made it
even more magical this is what you get
for homeschooling
[Music]